[Música]
goleiros duas notícias
a economia portuguesa continua debaixo
de uma enorme pressão
o défice orçamental está controlado mas
a dívida pública voltou suíço está neste
momento a 130 por cento do pib
se não fosse a política monetária do
banco central europeu então os juros
teriam muito mais altos
os impostos são altos aos treinando e
pesada o que o país precisa é de
reformas estruturais mas não cresce há
15 anos que praticamente a economia
portuguesa não creche e é por isso que
nós mantemos nível do investimento em
obrigações portuguesas abaixo do grau de
investimento à economia portuguesa é
fulgurante vive neste momento um momento
vibrante em que uma nova geração mostra
através de inovação e empreendedorismo
da ciência da cultura como é possível
dar a volta à crise
como é possível não cair na fatalidade e
mostra que é possível crescer a economia
está a começar para os pratos portugal é
neste momento o sítio certo para estar
para fazer negócios e para ser flu isso
estas duas notícias têm uma coisa em
comum a data foram publicadas no mesmo
dia
esta diz respeito ao relatório de uma
agência de rating que mantêm portugal
abaixo do nível do lixo
esta diz respeito ao relatório publicado
na revista moda com sobre portugal
qual das duas é verdade que só a teoria
do copo meio cheio do copo meio vazio
pensar num copo meio cheio meio vazio
apenas olhar para a metade do copo e
militava num cauteloso mas sim é sempre
uma tentativa que nós temos como diziam
antes voz nem vez ser otimistas ou
pessimistas eu era o silo lista
o neologismo diz que é sempre possível
fazer parte do que é bom mas então qual
das duas pessoas nos agarramos
entendemos agarrados a uma delas aliás
os circuitos de informação hoje são
brutalmente proporcionados pelas redes
sociais e as redes sociais tendem é
precisamente propagar as radicalizados
do discurso e nós nas redes sociais pelo
processo algorítmico entendemos e viciar
nos em ler pessoas que pensam exatamente
é que o que nós pensamos e isso cria uma
outra opção já tínhamos a opção da
dívida pública esta pressão é uma pessoa
muito mais invisível e do pensamento
único
pensem na palavra
vocês vieram aqui hoje porque causa do
pensamento para produzirem lançamento a
partir do pensamento que observam causa
das idéias para ter e sair a partir das
idéias que são compartilhadas por causa
da inspiração e expiração inspiração é
um bairro muito difícil ter acesso mas
todos nós queremos ser inspirados ao
longo das nossas vidas e alguns alguns
nós conseguem mesmo inspirar outras
pessoas e sim como exemplo a palavra é
muito importante para a inspiração mas a
inspiração estéreo não vale nada
com inspiração estéreo consegue como se
dizer sim tanto para a morte como são
sebastião fez é um câncer que vir era um
homem cheio de fé era um homem cheio de
crença cheio de praias cheias inspiração
se quisermos não tinha estratégia deus
que o frango pessoas a irem à loucura
que é o homem mais que esta sabia que
ela era diabética procria mas há outras
batalhas da inspiração ea nossa
estratégia em 1415
é uma batalha muito conhecida batalha
viagem curta guerra dos cem anos entre
inglaterra e frança aliás uma guerra que
durou mais de 100 anos e 1 415 a
princípio estamos no final da idade
média foi em 1415 portugal conquistou 75
portanto estava a iniciar o seu processo
de expansão aquilo que nós chamaríamos
dizer os descobrimentos mãe foi
precisamente neste ano no dia de são
crispim 25 de outubro que estes dois
exércitos se encontrar ainda véspera o
exército inglês estava desmoralizado
porque os franceses é um número muito
maior o exército não estava
desmoralizado estava quase lotado
e aí que o raio henrique quinto fala às
tropas
este discurso foi criado por websites pr
quinto e um discurso muito conhecido
o discurso durou apenas dois minutos já
que aos dois minutos henrique quinto
consegue transformar um exército que
está absolutamente lotado no exército
galvanizado e vitorioso na véspera da
batalha o discurso é muito conhecido por
uma das suas frases
o e fio e rap fio wimesh das provas é um
discurso de esperança é um discurso da
fraternidade nós um bando de irmãos
é um discurso humilde diz nós vamos
vencer e não precisa nem mais um homem
para vencer esta batalha e vocês nunca
mais no resto das nossas vidas vão
esquecer do dia são kristin e todos os
anos o estrago arregaçando as mangas
as cicatrizes e viram estas fritas eu
trouxe de são crispim inglaterra venceu
mas venceu não apenas porque tinha um
exército organizado mas porque havia uma
estratégia naquele discurso dois minutos
henrique pinto nunca fala nem uma só
palavra sobre a sua estratégia mas eu
tinha e estratégia foi basicamente
aproveitar as condições do terreno era
um lamaçal outro lion então os arqueiros
ingleses atiraram primeiro aos cavalos
em dante sátira dos campeões e os
cavalos as carcaças dos cavalos criar
uma espécie de muro que enrolou os
franceses e depois com uma aplicação e
uma técnica que nós também portugal
utilizados na batalha de aljubarrota
aliás auxiliados por estratégias em
inglês
os fãs ficaram calados e os ingleses
venceram inspiração sim e estratégia
esta batalha tem uma venda uma lenda
segunda qual foi aí que foi criado um
gesto que nós 600 anos depois os anos os
franceses antes da batalha para
amedrontar os ingleses dinheiro dito que
iriam cortar os dedos do maio a todos os
arcanjos do maio é essencial para armar
o arco
como os ingleses venceram então os
arcades ao ver o exército do tazio
os franceses mostraram que não apenas
não tenham prendido o dedo no maio
como tinham a palavra estratégia e
inspiração
mas como é que nós conseguimos
inspiração e aplicar a estratégia para
todas aquelas opções a opção das dívidas
às contas públicas
a opção do pensamento única com duas
embora não pareça e desfiliação
descontroladas informação como ter
inspiração estratégias somos tão
pequenos portugal portugal é um país
pequeno na europa ea união européia está
a tentar refazer para não se desfazer da
unir o país está entre os grandes blocos
econômicos nos estados unidos que eles
venham europa e musculada rússia em
emergência cada vez mais dominantes da
china e todos estes só estes estes
blocos econômicos que tendem a olhar
para a europa pelo menos assim parece
que é uma espécie de museu que vão
visitar as férias mas olha se para sul e
os migrantes transformam os refugiados
fugindo das guerras no médio oriente é
uma chacina e essa sina nasça e prospera
o turismo cancro tuta e ataca na europa
e tal como é que nós são pequenos
perante esta imensidão ao possível de
acontecimentos conseguindo ter força
conseguimos ter que ver capacidade
possibilidade de fazer o que quer que
seja como é que simonal mundo
mesmo usando aquela frase sendo na
verdade é que usar um mundo é também
mudar uma rua para mudar o mundo basta
levar a vida de uma pessoa já estamos a
mudar o mundo mas como durante aquelas
opções nem os próprios activa em
portugal
aquelas duas notícias confessam também
isto confesso que há coisas tocar em
portugal e que está a correr bem em
portugal é que nós estamos a ser
português
deixa eu explicar nós somos muito
cosmopolita ser mãe
contactamos com outras culturas
precisamos cada vez mais outras
nacionalidades conhecemos aprendemos com
todos os ensinamos também mas o
cosmopolitismo seis entidades é como
geral professor josué muito bonitos em
redes passando a parada
vento leva tudo ea nossa identidade que
nós vamos encontrar aquilo que está a
permitir nos para vencer superar chamei
o que quiserem
está o facto uma observação fax quiser
quando olhamos para a economia então nós
vemos é pelo aproveitamento dos nossos
recursos
nós estamos a crescer a agricultura da
fruta o azeite o vinho a cortiça a
floresta os produtos retirados da
floresta o papel da pasta de papel é os
frutos os os peões sim mas o turismo nós
sabemos que é uma espécie de descoberta
nossa o turismo é uma grande fonte de
crescimento do país
o turismo é porque é por causa das low
cost dos hotéis low cost som para todo
lado
hotéis há em todo o lado só o neymar
sempre tivemos nós olhamos muitas vezes
para fora para aprendermos e fazemos pai
neste assunto é que sabemos a diferença
entre invenção e inovação e inovação e
imitação e economia evolui essa barbárie
está correto do icms a nossa plágio
claro e então ouvimos coisas ao longo
dos anos como portugal tem que ser
aquela de forma da europa uma praia ou
então portugal tem que ser flórida da
europa um arsenal não
portugal tem que ter sido tentado da
europa chefe da ótica dos portugal não é
nem pelo fórum europa nem flórida na
europa nem se luca central da europa
portugal é o portugal da europa
porque é que os turistas vai cair é
porque os preços também são mais baratos
do piloto espanhol do doping em outras
capitais do país é provável mas vai-vai
as nossas cidades porque por causa da
nossa cultura
por causa do nosso património não apenas
do zoológico não apenas gastronômicos o
patrimônio também daquilo que nós somos
sim são os contratos longos aprovado mas
além disso somos muito hospitaleiros são
duas pessoas muito divertidas quando se
conseguir superar aquela película
reserva do time desde que temos são as
pessoas que gostam de contar histórias
de ouvir histórias sobre as pessoas não
querem testar fazemos parte portanto do
cosmopolitismo dos outros
isto é o que a entidade durante aquelas
opções para além das três cidades e
inspiração assente numa estratégia
observando que está a correr bem em
portugal a resulta da nossa identidade
resulta da nossa cultura então não somos
assim tão insignificantes a 7 mil
milhões de pessoas vivas neste momento
no planeta
cada um de nós é um 7000º milésimo temos
insignificante
nós não somos só nós somos portanto o
facto podemos mudar o curso dos
acontecimentos senão do mundo da nossa
rua da nossa casa de um amigo mas porque
temos mesmo capacidade de mudar o mundo
se num mundo então o país então ou então
a casa isso podemos fazê lo e se temos à
nossa disposição é nossa e incentivava
portanto não devemos imitar outros
devemos aproveitar é que o que de bom
temos e isso está a provar se ter
sucesso é isso que está a acontecer
portanto quando nós olhamos para as
diferenças por exemplo
após estas redes sociais ainda nas redes
sociais há coisas que se escrevem muito
claramente por exemplo que negativa vai
muito além dos factos por exemplo de uma
notícia tenta ser imparcial mas não tem
nem outra e percebi nada é uma atitude
de distanciamento
jô e necessária perante os factos mas é
neutralizado se neutro pode ser uma
covardia
max é neutro para o ataque terrorista
mas foi barrado não é a mesma coisa
realizava a nossa realidade pode nem
sequer ser provável a partir do
microcosmos a psicóloga ensina que nós
sentimos faz parte da nossa realidade
ainda que não seja aprovada se sentir
amado ou rejeitado e faz parte da minha
realidade mesmo que não seja vazado que
eu sou maluco isso rejeitada e isso são
ciclos de informação que também nos
manipula manipula muitas vezes em massas
e que também constituem um fator de
pressão e opressão
portanto se nos libertarmos de todas
essas dependências todas essas
influências que nos oprimem e olharmos
para aquilo que de facto sons e que está
com vai
não é pela central uma inspiração não é
apenas então sequer lugar disseram uns
são os portugueses não está funcionário
e portanto podemos seguir na nossa
própria inspiração se quiserem podemos
então decidir criar estratégia esteja
por uma empresa para um negócio próprio
esteja para a nossa própria atitude da
nossa própria vida
uma estratégia que beneficia das nossas
características
quem não é grande economia quem não é
grande tem que ser muito diferente para
nós a nossa diferença nossa
diferenciação está a produzir os
resultados que se vêem notícias como
aquela que tanto o que nós vamos fazer é
leve ball e se fosse vivo 3 70 anos
capital bens fosse vivo 3 50 anos se
fosse vivo quando são distintas
importantes vieram aqui para pensamento
pense nisto pensa nesse possível em
vaduz revelam todos os dias
comprovadamente e que resulta da nossa
própria identidade na nossa própria
cultura e ver que o que ela nos permite
afirmar mãos e portanto temos uma
espécie de spray nada nem que seja uma
propriedade pessoal e que os permite
coletivamente conseguiremos combater
esta opção ao superar esta crise mas
nesta desta forma visa de deus dizer
dizimar os caramba dizimados pelas
operações externas
vieram aqui por idéias então pensa em
aceitar é na ideia que certeza vamos nós
apenas 17 milésimos e nezinho
somos tantos tão gostoso esse vieram
aqui pra inspiração então espíritas em
vocês próprios porque tal naquelas duas
notícias
naquelas formados então o consequências
destas provados não será esmagarmos
desde a consequência parte de nós
[Aplausos]